réveil sous le choc ce samedi matin pour
les habitants de
conflans-sainte-honorine dans le
département des yvelines
la veille un professeur d'histoire
géographie
âgé de 47 ans a été froidement décapité
en pleine rue pour les conflanais et les
anciens élèves du collège
la situation semble tout simplement
irréel hommes comme beaucoup d'entre
nous nous sommes choqués par l'événement
qui vient de se passer
donc c'est un événement qui est
complètement inattendu et et ça se passe
à côté de chez nous donc on est on est
vraiment concerné par ce qui va se
passer sous le choc parce que nous c'est
un ancien professeur on est au lycée
maintenant mais c'est enfin c'était
choquant ça paraît irréel en fait de se
dire que il ya un professeur qui est
mort parce qu'il faisait son métier
nous on a eu ce cours là et ça s'est
très très bien passé et se dire que va
il est mort parce qu'ils à son métier et
en plus d'une façon horrible et enfin
c'était sous ce jeu très très choquant
un professeur tué pour avoir montré le 5
octobre dernier des caricatures du
prophète mahomet à ses élèves de 4e dans
cette ville paisible de la banlieue
parisienne
l'heure est au recueillement un soutien
psychologique a été mise en place au
collège
le maire de conflans-sainte-honorine
tente lui de rassurer ses administrés
il ya aujourd'hui au sein du collège le
bois donne une permanence de soutien
psychologique a été mise en place qui
est destiné aux parents d'élèves
destiné aux enseignants et surtout
destiné en premier aux élèves j'étais il
ya encore deux semaines au conseil de
sécurité de prévention de la délinquance
et le constat partagé par la préfecture
par la police nationale par la police
municipale et par les habitants par les
associations de prévention était le même
nous sommes ici à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans une ville
où il fait bon vivre
alors je dois dire aujourd'hui à mes
habitants que nous nous relèverons une
émotion aussi partagé par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans un tweet jean
michel blanquer rend hommage au
professeur et à sa famille comme le
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine
il évoque un besoin d'unité face à ce
nouvel attentat